I want you to think about the teacher
that you till today remember think about
that one teacher we all got one of them
minimum that we remember right today I'm
going to share with you how you can be
that teacher to many people in business
or in life because in reality as an
entrepreneur one of the things you'll do
a lot of teaching you'll teach your
clients you'll teach your vendors you'll
teach your partner's about your company
investors you'll teach your salespeople
you'll teach everybody about who you are
on what you do and the better you are at
teaching the better your business is
going to do and the more you're going to
grow because everyone's learning how to
take the stuff that you know in here and
implement it so let's get right into
step number one whatever you're teaching
sell what you're teaching let me explain
if you're teaching me math sell me the
importance of wanting to learn math sell
me sell it to me here's why math is so
important it's so exciting and
everything a life is math because if you
look at everything as angles and sports
is math and everything is not sell it to
me sell me whatever you're teaching step
number one number two if you can find a
way to add fun humor and creativity to
it what you do is this this is what
happens think about the mind being
closed-minded right so the mind is
closed every time you use fun humor or
creativity it opens up my mind just
think about visually I have a hole here
when it opens up my mind I'm willing to
have information enter my mind great
teachers know how to have fun humor
creativity open up the mind so they're
willing to be sold on whatever you're
teaching to the minutes if if the best
one if you know how to add sticky
stories to whatever you're teaching
using some sort of fun humor and
creativity it sticks forever people will
tell those stories forever and they'll
remember whatever you're teaching and
based on the story you told because when
they go home at that at night you know
what they're going to tell them hey
honey you won't believe what I learned
today would you learn did you know that
in 1976 Steve Jobs at Tata Tata and
because of that this is how the PC came
out and the mouse at the no way babe you
just saw them why they need to learn
this you added fun humor and creativity
I had a stinky story stuck there when I
taught their wife and their three kids
that night you're a great teacher number
three simplify make it look easy
whatever you do and make it look easy
don't complicate things make it very
make
look very easy number four give them
steps first you do this then you do that
then you do this give them simple steps
to follow that if they do they can do
what you're teaching them to do number
five so believe this is easy you can do
it it's not that hard
sell them the belief you can pull this
off right so if I'm teaching how to
shoot a basketball step number one bend
your knees to boom this is three it's
easy you can do it let's do it again
let's do it again let's do it again next
teach the way they learn some learn
visually some learn through reading some
learn through listening some learn
through hands-on teach so many different
ways that you can pretty much teach all
the different audiences on the way that
they learn whatever you are trying to
teach them next re remind this is
typically the biggest mistake teachers
make is because they forget to re remind
them Bri remind they say don't you
already get it haven't I already told
you I already told you this so for me
when I go home every night I ask both of
my sons what are the four things we
focus on as a family that elite love
respect improve do we bully no do we get
bullied no I've probably asked them this
to 300 times do you know why because
teaching is about re reminding not just
saying at one time and they remember
it's about reminding think about it like
a commercial Toyota does the same
commercial same commercial same
commercial and then you say it Dennis
you know the drink does the same
commercial same Commissioner you say re
remind you're like a commercial you're
doing to teach people next be patient
why because the speed of learning varies
for everybody some learn fast some Doorn
fast and sometimes the best students end
up being the one's that don't learn fast
so can you imagine if you go all in just
with a guy that learns very fast but
he's lazy then he got a guy here that
takes um six months to learn but he's
the hardest-working guy you got you got
to make sure you're varying based on
what speed learning they learn and last
but not least be a great student if
you're a great student typically the
greatest teachers make the greatest
students I don't know why that is
because you're so curious yourself
you're always learning people want to
learn from me because this thing's
always growing and people are excited
about that and it's like man this is so
cool if it if it's this exciting torrent
have one alarm if my teachers always
learning what if I learn like he learns
what if I want like she learns man I
want to learn
more so you got to be a great student in
order for you to be a great teacher and
last but not least last but not least
every time if you want your students to
be wanting to learn more and more and
more you got to make sure you encourage
them you praise them you recognize them
for instance there you go buddy you got
it down good job you made that shot
awesome job buddy that's exactly how you
write that sentence that's exactly how
that works you praise in front of people
did you guys see what Bobbi the great
job Bobby
then you recognize them the best top
three best students right now just want
to say Bobby because it is I got this
gift for you boom you did this you
recognized you praise you encouraged and
eventually people want to learn more
because you become the teacher that
everybody members forever and ever and
ever to come and when I ask somebody in
the future
hey who is the one teacher you will
never forget and they say your name I'm
talking to you they say your name
because all this stuff I just covered
with you you can learn so with that
being said Pauly this the shortest
episode we've done in a while
with our new pillow we got here from
Jennifer Mack much love to Jennifer Mack
hey you got questions comments about
what I just shot here post it on the
bottom if you want to send me question
about what I said here you can always
snappy the snap thing is right over here
I think it's somewhere on here right
David 1970 video it's a lot easier for
me to respond back and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel what are you
waiting for join the club of 170 some
thousand people that have already
subscribed to the number one channel on
YouTube for how-to for entrepreneurs
click this button here to subscribe and
click the notification right next to it
you become one the first to be notified
whenever new video goes up because we
have a goal of a million subs by the end
of 2017 and we need your help to help us
get there good catch Polly thanks for
watching everybody take care bye bye
[Music]